Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about 3D printing flexible molds
for objects with detailed geometry.
The main observation is that the final object
not only has to be cast, but also has to be
removed conveniently from the mold.
Finding an appropriate layout for the cuts
is a non-trivial problem.
The technique endeavors to have the least
amount of cuts, and the length of the cuts
is also subject to minimization.
I see the light bulb lighting up in the heads
of our seasoned Fellow Scholars, immediately
noticing that this sounds like an optimization
problem.
And in this problem, we start out from a dense
cut layout, and iteratively remove as many
of these cuts as possible until some prescribed
threshold is met.
However, we have to be vigilant about the
fact that these cuts will result in deformations
during the removal process.
We mentioned before that we're interested
in shapes that have geometry that is rich
in details, therefore this distortion effect
is to be minimized aggressively.
Also, we cannot remove these cuts indefinitely,
because sometimes, more cuts have to be added
to reduce the stress induced by the removal
process.
This is a cunning plan, however, a plan that
only works if we can predict where and how
these deformations will happen, therefore
we have to simulate this process on our computer.
During removal, forces are applied to the
mold, which we also have to take into consideration.
To this end, there is an actual simulation
of the entirety of the extraction process
to make sure that the material can be removed
from the mold in a non-destructive manner.
Wow!
The paper discusses tons of issues that arise
from this problem formulation, for instance,
what one should do with the tiny air bubbles
stuck in the resin.
Or, the optimization part is also non-trivial,
to which a highly effective homebrew solution
is presented.
And there's a lot more, make sure to have
a look!
Of course, as always, we would love to hear
your ideas about possible applications of
this technique.
Leave your thoughts in the comments section!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!